this project is a sign language
translator it translates from one sign
language to another it helps the hearing
and the Deaf communicate Nihao
imagine a deaf person walking into a
doctor's office the doctor is a regular
doctor probably can't speak in sign
language hello my name is dr. Wong what
is hurting you but the patient wants to
communicate with the doctor today they'd
have to use their maybe writing and it
would be very artificial but here with
this technology they could use signing
and the doctor would be able to
understand that that signing another
scenario is a and information cubes
hello how can I help you
and rather than say the person seeking
information at that kiosk mean deaf
imagine if the person that the
information kiosk was was deaf which way
is the taxi stand now a hearing person
could come to that kiosk and ask
questions of the deaf person and the
system can help them communicate with
the deaf person who knows
please go outside the terminal and make
a left great thank you